pascal praud a déclaré à l'issue de la
rencontre psg marseille
la pelouse était humide et vous bonjour
santé 1,50 et donc vous appelez nabila
je fais un petit résumé de votre
carrière donc vous aimez bien le
shampoing ouais j'aime trop voilà pascal
praud a déclaré à l'issue de la
rencontre psg marseille
la pelouse était humide et vous si votre
copain et air dessert ce serait plutôt
un mystère une religieuse ou un gland
comme quoi un gland cesser le gâteau
vert avec des trucs qu'on longe comme ça
quoi un gland ne connaissez pas mais non
ce n'est pas un gâteau qui s'appelle un
passage aux urnes offrir avec plaisir à
9,6 à ces super bon c'est comme une
religieuse au chocolat ou seulement
j'avais tellement glaise de dents chez
ce que c'est un glass a des trucs qui
tombe des arts donc sans parler de dieu
ne fait pas un gâteau d'un gâteau un
moment il ya un autre va chercher
chercher sur internet
si après on fait comment bah vous me
voulez pas aussi la page vous parler de
mon cas la question que je pose souvent
et à tout le monde en période électorale
hum hum vous embêter ce que j'étais
j'étais en train de regarder mes tweets
alors c'est quoi le dernier par exemple
on est on est curieux vous me suivez pas
sur twitter voulait que vous suivre sur
twitter même je vous suivent sur twitter
vous avez twitter vous déjà je vous
promets vous avez pas vous n'avez pas la
tête à voir twitter je vais avoir quoi
je suis pas lié à l'express le moule et
vous avez un fax depuis 15 jours parce
qu'avant j'en voyais tout par la poste
ou tanger un fax la baie qui sait qu'il
fait ça genre je crois que quand j'en ai
pas beaucoup donc ils ont donc peut-être
qu'ils ont d'autres trucs de 10 ans à
eux mais moi je leur lis moi je vous
envoie un fax mais faut se mettre aux
mails vous croyez ah ouais c'est
important parce qu'il faut que vous me
parlez des truqueurs préhistorique
c'est une période électorale que pensez
vous des candidats sans étiquette
candidat sans étiquette
ça veut dire quoi sans étiquette crise
ou pas sont pas une étiquette
ouf mais ce qu'ont perdu qua non à
partir de quel moment un livre n'est pas
un livre bas
ça s'est un peu compliqué pour moi c'est
un magazine est un magazine peut être un
livre ou pas ah non un livre à ya un
glee allegro livre en page et les petits
livres les magazines la dépense de la
taille d'un magazine avec plein de pages
on peut considérer sans un livre bah
ouais voilà tout et bah je sais tout
ouais je vous remercie
[Musique]